Christ
[Music]
this is considered the traditional
staple for most people most mornings we
have the fried bread English bacon which
is English back bacon it's obviously a
different taste to the American bacon
the pork sausage which we have made with
our British butcher Heinz baked beans
which are imported baked beans from
England fried tomatoes grilled tomatoes
here then underneath we've got fried
mushrooms the black pudding which is
also known as blood pudding while where
I'm from the West Midlands it's known as
a delicacy I think American bacon is
better it's greasy er I mean if you're
gonna get something unhealthy just like
go all the way you know this is really
good it's really hearty but I think ours
is just a little bit better this looks
more like a hotdog
well my taste buds are telling you is
that this is deep-fried and butter and
it's fantastic mmm Oh Margo Haut who
makes better toast England I feel like
it's so random Denton to have just a
plain tomato for breakfast well I'm not
a big fan of tomatoes I can appreciate a
tomato and this is a really really good
one mushrooms they're okay I feel like
these belonging in on that on their own
may seem lonely are beans of vegetable
also beans not a breakfast food in
America you know what if I could have
the sauce in the beans that's good
English breakfast is basically like a
barbecue black pudding is made of blood
it kind of looks like a corn beef hash
it's got like little like nuggets in
there I don't know what those are I'm
not a big fan of it on its own pudding
its chocolate and dessert in sweet you
totally gonna have black pudding listen
I mean this has been a very interesting
experience but to be honest I still cook
the American breakfast is a strong one
English breakfast is better than
American breakfast I'm sorry this is
cinnamon toast crunch
I think this wins you gotta give it to
America because America you can have
dessert for breakfast you know
you know like you can have something
sweet you have something savory this
just feels like dinner so it's a tie I
think we might have just started the
second Revolutionary War